autre mobilisation nationale notamment à
toulouse cette fois ci contre le projet
de loi bioéthique qui vise à ouvrir la
pma à toutes les femmes
le texte arrive en deuxième lecture en
séance publique au sénat mardi prochain
le collectif d'associations en marche
aux enfants demandent son retrait au
moins sa réécriture en profondeur les
manifestants dénoncent le bouleversement
du principe de filiation ainsi qu une
marchandisation de la procréation
je pense qu'il est essentiel que nous
manifestions pour les valeurs de la
france nous sommes égarés en tournant
sociétal vraiment fort inquiétant voilà
le la manif pour tous et là je vous le
dire la loi bioéthique
on va dire mobiliser plus la tension
actuellement en cette période de kovy
d'arte ce projet de loi bioéthique qui
va être votée va changer complètement
notre façon de vivre dans les années à
venir à venir en bouleversant
complètement le principe de la filiation
en proclamant en autorisant la
procréation médicalement assistée
non seulement aux couples stériles c'est
à dire des personnes qui sont malades
qui ont besoin de soins en levant des
personnes qui sont en bonne santé mais
qui ne peuvent naturellement pas avoir
d'enfant c'est à dire des femmes
célibataires ou des couples de femmes
homosexuelles et bien là on ne provoque
une rupture sociétal qui n'est ni bio ni
éthique